lying in hospital she was barely able to
speak mum
hello Marie shenton's family was shocked
by how unwell she'd become I can't
believe it's her
I just can't but she doesn't look like
Marie at all as she's deteriorated in
them two days
it's scary
but that's what 15 hours of numbers to
Australia Marie had just turned 70. this
was taken days before she fell ill in
late November she always looked so nice
her family called an ambulance when she
began vomiting blood she was taken to
Torbay hospital but faced a 15-hour wait
in the ambulance before she was admitted
by then she was very ill eventually a
room was found for her but then the
family were called to say she'd fallen
out of bed she died soon afterwards I
got to the hospital about 10 minutes
after she'd passed away
and so it was quite traumatic it was
awful
um
I don't know what's happened
I just want some answers that's all I
want to know why my sister fell out the
bed for a storm why in this day and age
15 hours in in a an ambulance well like
a third world country and were one of
the richest countries going and this is
happening the government have got to do
something that the car just keep letting
this happen my sister's dead because she
was in an ambulance for 15 hours and
that's not right the family described
the paramedics who cared for Marie as
amazing and blamed the hospital for what
happened these images show ambulances
queuing there this month in a statement
the health secretary said the government
is taking urgent action to ease
pressures on a e departments including
more investment to free up beds the
medical director for the tour Bay and
South Devon NHS Foundation trust said we
would like to send our heartfelt
condolences to Mrs shenton's family we
don't want anyone waiting in an
ambulance longer than necessary and all
patients arriving at our emergency
department are triaged and assessed with
the most clinically urgent being
prioritized Bridget who spent her career
as a healthcare assistant is angry I
work for the NHS for 37 years
up until 2017 and I can't believe what's
happening I can't believe it
it's it's scary very scary she fears her
family won't be the last to suffer Becky
Johnson Sky News